so i have a question for you
would you ever
consume
salmon that is gray the answer is no
right well what if i were to give you
gray salmon that has used food dye to
make it look pink would you consume it
well chances are you are if you're
consuming farm-raised salmon in a recent
video i talked about the healthiest food
that you could possibly eat is salmon
but i really made a big distinction
between wild caught and farm raised now
just because they're similar doesn't
mean they're the same but today i want
to focus just on one
big difference it's the coloring now the
way that they make
farm raised salmon pink is they use
something called a synthetic
astaxanthin that is a pigment compound
which also appears in nature
and in nature
natural astaxanthin has
huge profound health benefits but the
synthetic version there's never been any
credible safety studies to show that
it's safe for humans now the reason i'm
bringing that up is because there has
been a lot of research on synthetic
antioxidants and the dangers that it can
actually increase your risk of
cancer
so since this is also a synthetic
antioxidant you should just realize that
there is no safety studies and the
problem with the situation is if someone
does find
a problem with this uh in some study
it's going to take probably 20 years
before it's taken off the market so
certain companies have synthesized
this compound
out of petrochemicals and they even sell
different shades of pink okay so they
have this color wheel very similar to
you going
to the paint store and trying to find
the right paint we have these different
colors on this chart it's called a samol
fan and you can pick and choose the
color pigment that you want
people will definitely spend more money
on salmon if it's a dark colored pink
and also they do this with egg yolks to
make it look really um like a golden
yellow orange that's also produced by
these synthetic they're called
carotenoids also chicken is also dyed
because if you don't have it the nice
pink
flesh color
people might not eat it so this is just
another reason
to get wild caught salmon pasture-raised
organic eggs and to buy organic chicken
that is not colored not to mention
flavored yes they also flavor chicken
because it's so bland but the next time
you're in the grocery store look at the
back of the label when you buy chicken
it'll say chicken with
natural flavorings okay they actually
put chicken flavoring to make the
chicken taste more like chicken now i'm
doing a really big deep dive on
antioxidants
phytonutrients and doing testing with
plants and how you would spike certain
phytonutrients or pigments in plants and
you can do it with certain nutrients in
the soil you can do it with different
types of light so it's a fascinating
subject because there are a lot of
health benefits from some of these
pigments so i just want to run down the
list of all the great benefits of a
natural astaxanthin first of all it's 50
times stronger in its ability to counter
oxidation it's 20 times stronger in
handling free radicals and what i'm
comparing is the synthetic aversion and
like i said before it has profound
benefits on humans
for your eye for your brain
for your heart for your immune system it
gives you uv protection with your skin
it even has anti-inflammatory properties
so it can do a lot so the salmon get
astaxanthin from krill
and shrimp okay
and the krill and shrimp get it from
microalgae and so microalgae are just
loaded with this pigment now just as
aside now what's fascinating about
this compound and microalgae is that
when algae is stressed whether it's heat
or cold
or a lack of food they eat up a lot of
this astaxanthin it's called bile
accumulation but in a hyper mode then
they can actually live to up to 40 years
in extreme environments and i'm talking
about extreme cold extreme heats in
environments where there's no food or
water it's a fascinating protective
survival mechanism so there are profound
benefits from humans from consuming this
compound but of course when you get it
from farm-raised fish it's not going to
be the same that chemistry is completely
different and one last point about
astaxanthin in nature it always comes
as a complex at least five other
carotenoids but when you synthesize it
in a lab it only comes
in one
form so other than the obvious reasons
not to consume farm-raised fish like
they're fed gmo soy and corn this
synthetic version of astoxanthin
could potentially be a problem if anyone
decides to do the safety studies now i
think the next most important video to
watch would be
what i think is the healthiest food to
eat which is wow caught salmon check it
out i put it right here
you